So now you know enough about Python to be able
to solve the problem that we started with at the
beginning of this unit, which the problem of extracting a
link from its page. Before we get to the code,
I want to describe a little more carefully what's going
on in a webpage. So we've talked about strings in
Python and all a web page really is, is a
long string. When you see a web page in your browser,
it doesn't look like that. So here's an example web
page, one of my favorite XKCD comics. And hopefully, you're
starting to learn enough about Python to appreciate the power
of Python to make you fly. Probably the rest of
the comic, if you haven't done anything other than using
Python, is a little hard to relate for now. But
it's making fun of other languages where there's an awful
lot of work to do something simple, like we've seen here,
just being able to print out a string. But with
Python, we can fly quickly, and you're going to learn to fly
very quickly in this class. This doesn't lok like just
a string. We've seen just a string is a sequence of
characters. When we look at a webpage like this, well
we see images. We see buttons. We see some text. We
see things that are links and you can see the
underlines these are all links. And the browser renders the webpage
in a way that looks attractive. What actually was
there though, started just as a stream of text.
If you right-click on the webpage, one of the
options you see is View Page Source. When you click
on that, you'll see the actual source code. This is what came into the browser.
So, your browser sent a request, the URL is what's shown in the address bar.
So, it's sent a request to xkcd.com/355.
It sent that request and this is what came back. What came back is just a stream
of text. We can look at that text and some of it is fairly hard to understand.
So what's important is the links. Here's an
example of a link. So, the link starts with
a tag like this. The language HTML uses these
angle brackets. And the angle bracket a href equals
is how we start a link. That's followed by
a string which is surrounded by double quotes, similarly
to a string in Python. So, we have a
double quote. Between the double quotes is a URL. The
URL is the way of locating content on the
web so here we have the URL http colon, that
means it's a web request. We'll talk more in
a later class about what http means and the protocols
used to request web pages. What's important now is, that's a
location If we open that in a web browser, that will give
us another page. What I'm looking at here is the link that
is underneath the text for News/Blag. If we click on that link,
that will take us to the page blag.skcd.com. That
was the page that we saw in the link
here it said vlad.skcd.com. When we click on the
link, that's where we went. So to build our crawler,
what we want to do for each webpage, we want
to find these links in the page. We're going to keep
track of those links and we're going to follow them
to find more content on the web. This is similar
to what someone would do if their browsing. If they're
clicking on every link of a page, following all the links
they find, looking at all that content. That's a really good
way to waste a horrendous amount of time if you do
that yourself. We're going to build a web crawler that can
do that automatically. So our goal is to take the text
that came back from a web request, find a link in
that text, which is going to be a tag that starts
with a href equals and then extract from that
tag the URL of the webpage that it links to.
Those are the URLs that we're going to use in
our crawler to make progress. So by using what we've
learned about strings, and what you've learned about variables,
you know enough to be able to do that. What
we want to do is find the beginning of a tag.
And what the beginning of a tag is this text
right we're looking for something that matches exactly the a href
equals part. That's what the tags were here they all start
with a href equals. Not all webpages have the same structure. There are lots
of other ways to make a tag. The A
could be a capital letter for example. There could
be more spaces between the a and the href.
The double quote doesn't actually need to be there.
For what we do now, we're going to assume that
all our webpages follow the same structure that we're seeing
here. That each link starts with an a h ref
without any funny spaces or anything else. Has an equal,
has a double quote, has the URL following that,
and then another double quote. So that means we're looking
for strings like this, we're looking to find the a
href; that's followed by a double quote. After the double
quote is the URL. This is what we actually care
about; we want to find the URLs on the Web page.
That's followed by a closing double quote and then, there's
more that closes the tag. And there's lots of other
stuff on both sides of this. But this is what
we want to do. We want to find the tags that are
links and then, within the tags that are links, we
want to find the URLs. So we're going to assume that we
start with the page contents in a variable. We'll
call that page, and we're not going to worry today
about how we got those page contents. We're going to
provide a function that does that. For the code
that you have today, let's going to assume the
page is already initialized. That it contains the content
of some web page stored as a string and our goal is to find the URL of the first
link in the page. That's going to involve a couple
steps. SO what we want to do is find the start
of the link. We want to find where we have the
a href equals. We can't just look for the first string
we find, because there's lots of other strings on the
page that aren't URLs. So I think you know enough to
do that, so we'll make it a quiz. So your goal
for this quiz is to write some Python code that will
initialize the variable start link to be the
value of the position where the first a
href equals. So the first tag that starts
a link occurs in page, so you should assume
that page starts with the content of some
web page, and what we're doing is looking for
the place where the first a href equals
occurs, and that's the first link on the page.